você já parou para pensar quem são as
pessoas que estão por trás dos produtos
que você consome
quem produziu a roupa que você está
investindo nesse momento tivessem feito
essa pergunta alguns quatro anos atrás
mais ou menos eu teria respondido que eu
não sabia
hoje eu vim aqui compartilhar com vocês
algumas informações da indústria da moda
e como ela tem evoluído e mudado ao
longo dos tempos é nosso últimas décadas
a principal intenção das grandes
varejistas foi criar produtos baratos
sem se importar com as consequências
negativas geradas para vocês terem uma
idéia nas últimas duas décadas o
consumir moda aumentou 500%
tudo isso entre tantas outras
consequências trouxe o desperdício
têxtil que hoje para vocês terem uma
idéia 12 toneladas de resíduos têxteis
são jogados fora em são paulo na região
do bom retiro
mas aí eu pergunto pra vocês
você já parou para pensar que não existe
jogar fora
na verdade não existe jogar no lixo tudo
o que a gente não quer mais vai parar em
algum lugar do mundo em 2013 alguns de
vocês devem ter visto aconteceu um
trágico acidente e mandou a 10 na
capital daka onde uma um prédio veio
abaixo com mais de mil pessoas
essas pessoas trabalhavam em condições
extremamente precárias em fábricas que
fornecem produtos para grandes
varejistas
para vocês terem uma noção essas pessoas
recebiam em média de 3 dólares por dia
numa jornada de mais ou menos 12 horas
em seis dias por semana
uma outra notícia vocês devem ter visto
também em 2014 onde algumas pessoas
encontraram dentro das suas próprias
roupas pedidos de socorro de pessoas que
trabalhavam nessas
as fábricas mas a gente não tem só
notícias ruins também
então ao longo de deus esses acidentes
enfim que inclusive a gente ouviu falar
aqui no brasil mesmo então esses
problemas são muito mais próximos do que
a gente imagina eles não estão lá na
china só em bangladesh
hoje a gente tem notícias também de
histórias bacanas que estão acontecendo
de pessoas e movimentos em busca de uma
moda mais ética mais sustentável e por
um consumo mais consciente
eu acredito realmente que com pequenas
atitudes
nós podemos causar microevoluções vou
contar uma experiência um pouquinho pra
vocês de em 2012
eu participei de uma experiência de
mobilização social numa comunidade onde
eu experiência na prática o que era a
diferença entre simpatia e empatia e
nessa experiência consegui perceber que
eu posso ter empatia em relação a alguma
pessoa ou em relação a alguém e
continuar minha vida do mesmo jeito sem
fazer nada para mudar ou eu posso dizer
se eu posso ter empatia e aí entra uma
questão que realmente considero que pode
ser um fator fundamental para a gente
conseguir cidades mais humanas
depois dessa experiência ficou muito
claro pra mim ainda que reluta se um
pouco por alguns anos que eu queria um
pouco mais dessas experiências chamadas
sociais dos trabalhos voluntários já
tinha feito vários trabalhos voluntários
por algum tempo e nesta experiência eu
senti uma voz lá dentro chamando um
pouco mais forte dizendo que era isso
que eu tinha que seguir fazendo então eu
percebi que a maneira que eu queria
fazer isso seria empreendendo empreender
foi a forma que eu descobri que eu
poderia criar esse mundo que eu
tanto buscava mas que parecia tão
distante buscando opções dentro desses
modelos tradicionais que a gente está
acostumado a ver
é depois dessa de perceber isso eu me
juntei a mais uma pessoa amiga e nós
começamos a convivência manualmente
nessa comunidade
e nessa convivência ficou muito claro
pra gente o que a gente queria fazer na
verdade não ficou claro que a gente
queria fazer mas sim com quem a gente
queria fazer e depois essa convivência
inicial a gente é por algum tempo os
dois ou três meses
ainda que a gente não soubesse qual
seria o resultado final
a gente tinha muito claro que daquelas
pessoas a gente queria entender quais
eram as habilidades que elas tinham e
qual era a intenção em comum que existia
naquele grupo
além disso a gente sabia que a gente não
queria enxergar não enxergava aquelas
pessoas que eram artesãos não apenas
como mão de obra
essa questão do trabalho na verdade
enxergava como o diferencial
a gente queria que as pessoas fizessem
parte de todo um processo criativo que
normalmente elas só entram no final na
hora da produção tão pra gente fazer
muito sentido que ela se envolvesse
nesse processo de criação desde o início
e depois dessa convivência de alguns 4
ou 5 meses criando junto com essas
mulheres e com essas pessoas
a gente deu vida uma iniciativa que hoje
se chama colibri
a colibri iria lá é uma empresa que
nasce com a intenção de aproximar essas
realidades diversas para promover o
impacto social
na verdade a maneira que a gente
encontrou e que a gente tem feito até
então é através do desenvolvimento de
produtos a partir do reaproveitamento de
resíduos testes junto a essas artesãs de
comunidades
é nesse grupo de mulheres que a gente
encontrou e que se identificaram com a
gente na verdade foi uma identificação
mútua
a gente encontra uma pessoa muito
importante que faz parte da nossa
história desde o início essa pessoa é a
eni a eni - em entender lá no início
como era nossa proposta na verdade nem a
gente entendia muito bem o que a gente
queria fazer então era um pouco difícil
de entender mas eu acho que alguma coisa
ela percebeu na gente e desde o início
ela se jogou junto e ao longo desses
anos são quase três anos mais ou menos
eu vejo uma mudança uma transformação
enorme
vejo hoje uma pessoa mais determinada
eu vejo uma pessoa mais confiante e que
tem certeza do trabalho que ela faz e
sente orgulho do trabalho que ela faz
pra você ser um pouquinho da idéia da
questão de empoderamento que tanto se
fala né a gente escuta muito comum e 61
poderão tanto tantas mulheres né
e na verdade o que a gente costuma falar
é que a gente não poderá ninguém na
verdade esse poder tá dentro de cada uma
de nós está dentro de cada uma daquelas
mulheres que a gente trabalha o que a
gente faz na verdade criar um meio para
que esse poder seja possa ser analisado
para vocês terem uma idéia da
importância da eni dessas mulheres nessa
criação do da colibri desde o início e
até hoje
aí significação de resíduos têxteis é
algo que veio da indicação delas foi uma
sugestão do próprio grupo pra gente no
início não fazia o menor sentido talvez
por algum apego a padrões um próprio
preconceito nosso mas chegou no momento
que acho que foi inevitável quando a
gente chegou com ele pra n falou n que
tu acha da gente fazer uma mochila
para vocês terem uma noção a n era uma
coisa era costureira de vestuário
então nesse processo existe um
desenvolvimento muito grande por parte
de todo mundo eu acabei não falando
antes mas esse desenvolvimento aconteceu
pra gente também porque como foi falado
na apresentação a sua formado em direito
e essa minha amiga
é formado em economia então imaginem
como era importante esse processo de
criação para todas nós a gente precisava
trocar essas informações
a gente precisava trocar os
conhecimentos então n num determinado
momento falou assim
por isso eu vou seguir em frente vou
seguir me desafiando mas eu também quero
que vocês aceitem as nossas sugestões e
daí quando a gente falou de fazer uma
mochila a primeira coisa que veio na
cabeça da eni foi vamos fazer uma
mochila de calça jeans
afinal de contas tem tanto as calças
jeans por aí no mundo sobrando desde o
início da cobrança outra coisa muito
importante além desse processo de
criação integrando todas essas pessoas é
a questão da remuneração justa
a gente via que não fazia o menor
sentido só um lado sai ganhando com
muitas vezes acontece pra gente
precisava ser uma relação de ganha ganha
então desde o nosso início a gente tem
um cuidado de mostrar um pouco o que
está por trás dos produtos que a gente
vende
então a gente não vende só um produto a
gente tenta passar toda a história que
está por trás dele
todo o processo de criação e produção
que acontece do início ao fim
a gente imagina que assim as pessoas
conseguem entender um pouco mais toda a
dificuldade desse processo tudo que
existe por trás e consigam valorizar um
pouco mais esse trabalho
outra coisa também que surgiu com n
foi um sentimento que ela tinha desde o
início que ela compartilhou com a gente
num dos primeiros encontros que a gente
teve em que ela falou pra gente que um
dos maiores sonhos dela era ver os
produtos que ela fazia se espalhando
pela cidade e daí foi um pouco engraçado
porque ela dizia eu tenho essa visão
aqui de cima do morro eu vejo tanta
gente lá embaixo que não me conhece não
conhece meus produtos como seria legal
que essas pessoas conhecessem e me
conhecessem e pensando um pouco como a
gente poderia fazer essa aproximação
entre essas realidades tão diversas
desde o início também a gente coloca
dentro dos produtos que a gente vende
esse bilhetinho com uma frase em que a
própria teresa escolhe
enfim
seja autoral ou alguma outra alguma
inspiração em que ela se sente
representada essa é a maneira que a
gente encontrou nós encontramos na
verdade de representar todo o nosso
trabalho
você se lembra daquele chegaram àquele
bilhetinho eu falei antes de
trabalhadores pedindo ajuda
então a gente pode ver que existem
soluções se a gente não quer mais aquele
tipo de bilhete pedindo socorro
a gente quer outro tipo de bilhete
desde o início o que eu sinto é que a
gente passou por diversas transformações
por muitos desafios mas desde o início
eu tive muito claro que eu tinha pessoas
ao meu lado que acreditavam e que me
faziam continuar em frente
mesmo com todos os desafios e com todos
enfim todos os empecilhos que surgem no
meio desse caminho que empreender e
ainda empreender social socialmente
falando um pouco de inovação é a gente
vê que é um pouco difícil mas o que eu
acredito que a gente tem que sair um
pouco das bolhas tem muita gente
procurando essas coisas que estão
acontecendo então a gente tem que se
reunir e compartilhar um pouco dessas
histórias
às vezes quando está trabalhando na
correria do dia a dia a gente acha que a
gente está sozinho nessa história na
verdade a gente não tá tem muitas redes
colaborativas tem muitas pessoas que
estão procurando fazer diferente e uma
essas pessoas eu falando um pouco da
alegria a gente está dentro de um espaço
que se chama vila flores que é uma casa
colaborativa e nesse espaço que já está
desde o início do ano então são é quase
um ano na verdade de experiência numa
casa colaborativa onde a gente encontrou
pessoas que têm que buscam propósitos
que buscam uma cidade melhor que buscam
uma vida melhor e quando a gente está
cercado e rodeado de pessoas que buscam
esse propósito
tudo fica mais fácil a gente não se
sente sozinho a gente se sente muito
apoiado falando um pouquinho das cidades
inclusivas e trazendo esse contexto de
casas colaborativas
o que eu realmente espero é que a gente
possa assim com essas experiências de
cidades mais humanas cidades mais
inclusivas onde a gente não encontra
tantas barreiras onde a gente não
encontra tantos limites onde as
condições sociais não seja um limite
para as pessoas transitarem entre os
espaços onde a cor da pele também não
seja um limitador para transitar entre a
cidade
eu acredito muito que a melhor forma de
prever o futuro ajudar a criá lo
vocês lembram daquela pergunta que eu
fiz lá no início eu vou no meu tempo mas
eu queria muito fazer essa reflexão pra
vocês se lembram da pergunta o que você
você sabe quem são as pessoas que estão
por trás dos produtos que você consome
eu acredito que isso é muito importante
está na hora da gente parar pra pensar
se a gente não parou
convido você a fazer parte desse futuro
vamos todos juntos fazer essas micro
revoluções ligado
[Aplausos]